In this lesson, we're going to take a look at some of the modeling tools that allow us
to edit our LODs.
So let's get started.
So the tool we're going to be looking at is the modeling tool editor that is found within
the plugins.
And once you turn it on, Unreal will ask you to reboot.
And we're not going to go through all the aspects of the tool, but we're going to primarily
look at being able to simplify a model as well as being able to change its pivot so
that you can actually get things in position and get the look that you need.
Once you have it active, you can actually go to it through the pull down menu and select
modeling.
You can also access it with shift five.
That'll get you where you need to go.
So let's go ahead and take a look at these two sections here when it comes to simplifying
and looking at the mesh.
So in Unreal here, we can go ahead and switch to our modeling.
And in here, you'll see that we have several different topics that we can choose from with
our subcategories in here in there.
What we're going to mainly focus on is to the transform one and the mesh one.
The transform one's pretty simple.
I can select any model in my scene.
Let me hit the F key and say this model doesn't quite have the pivot I want because I built
it wrong or one of my contractors did.
It ended up being bigger than we needed and we ended up scaling it in an engine.
You can actually change this here with the edit pivot tool.
This allows me to be able to move it in any area that I need, which is pretty convenient.
Once we move it into the position that we want and we can choose bottom, top, right, back,
you simply hit accept.
I'm going to hit cancel for that.
You kind of get it.
It is way better than the older way that we do things, which was the cumbersome pivot tool here.
This doesn't quite work as well, but this tool is miles ahead.
Let's go ahead and look at the mesh tool and what it can do.
So before we get too far ahead, we want to make sure that we check and turn on a few
things in our settings.
Let me go to my project settings and show you what I mean.
In my project settings, if you're going to be editing the models, you want to make sure
that you turn these on, specifically if you're working with ray tracing.
But I like to turn them on anyway if I'm in Lumen because some of the technology for ray
tracing, mainly to speed things up and leaning on the hardware ray tracing aspect, is there
in place and I just want to make sure there's no hiccups.
So what I'll do is I'll put modeling in here and I'll make sure that I'll turn on enable
ray tracing for a new mesh object as well as enable ray tracing while editing.
This is great to actually turn on as a precautionary measure, especially if you're going from Lumen
back to ray tracing, etc.
And it just covers your bases there just so that things are updating accordingly in our
environment.
All right, so let's go and take a look at our tools here for the mesh.
I'm going to turn this on here and let's go ahead and take a look at this polygon
object and see what it looks like.
I'm going to click on the magnifying glass with a folder.
Now first thing you want to do is determine whether this thing is Nanite or not.
The tools will still work if they're not Nanite, but I just wanted to show you say you brought
in a model and you decided it doesn't need to be as high as it's marked.
Maybe you want to just downgrade it a little bit because it's way in the background.
There's no need to use it.
Nanite's pretty clean, so you don't necessarily have to worry about that.
But you may want to say there's a really high level of detail scan and you're noticing,
man, I don't really need it to be that detailed.
I just need to sell a web.
You can actually go in here and simplify that mesh.
You can also float over each model and get an idea what the polygons look like.
This will also tell you whether it's Nanite enabled.
You can see here on this particular one, we have Nanite off.
On this particular one, Nanite is on.
As you float over, it will tell you that Nanite is true.
It says enabled there.
It will even give you a Nanite vertices and triangles.
Let's pick on this particular one.
This one is not Nanite enabled, as we can see.
Let's activate that tool.
I'm going to click away and we're going to go in here, select this tool.
We're going to go to simplify.
Now there's multiple choices that you can choose from here in simplification.
I'm not going to go through too much buttonology.
I do have this laid out in our lecture notes.
Two of them, which work pretty well, is the normal aware, which allows you and allows
Unreal to honor your normals, take them into account.
UE standard, this is the one I typically choose.
This one actually works really, really well.
We can work through triangle percentage here.
Again, it ballparks it.
If you were to choose, say, you want to do exactly triangle count, it's going to also
estimate it here, just like it would with Maya, Houdini, or 3ds Studio Max.
It's going to give an approximation.
I'll keep it percentage for now.
I think that works pretty well.
Do we want to drop it 50%?
Why not?
We'll go ahead and do that.
Let's go ahead and drop that.
One thing I want to point out, though, before I get into this, is you want to make sure
you have a copy of your geo in the scene, because if, say, you like the original and
you want to dumb it down to see what it looks like, keep in mind it's going to dumb down
the polygons on all the instances in your environment, which is not exactly ideal.
You might want to duplicate it in the content browser.
Let me hit cancel for a second.
Just find that piece of geometry, and you can see I have several duplicates here.
Duplicate them, drag them in the scene, and then run a procedural, I should say, a simplification
on it, and then kind of see how it looks and what you want.
Instead of doing it on one, which may be in several different areas, it may not fit the
bill.
All right.
So let's click on simplification, keep it at percentages, keep it at unreal standard,
and we'll do 50%, and let's go ahead and hit accept.
We'll let it run there.
It's going to be running for us.
There it goes, pretty fast.
Now you can find that piece of geometry, and we can now see that it's been dropped.
It was 47, I think 47, almost 53,000 triangles.
Now it's 23, and it actually looks pretty good still.
Now again, keep in mind it still has the high resolution texture.
You can also dump that down using virtual textures, which we'll talk briefly about later.
But for the most part, we're actually in here, and it worked really, really well.
All right.
So say you have it in your scene, though, and you kind of want to replace maybe another
one in your scene.
But you're like, you know what?
I have this guy, and there's several of them I want to replace.
I'm going to hit shift E, and let's see if there's any duplicates.
No, there's not.
We'll just pretend there's is.
So let's go and make some duplicates really quick.
So I go to Alt, there's another one, rotate it just a little bit.
So this is like too generic.
Move that back, not too far back, and then we do Alt and move.
So if I have multiples in the scene, I can hit shift E, and it will select them.
With them selected, I can right click, and I can replace that actor with the one that
I've just dumped down, which actually works pretty well.
Now if you're not sure, you can go in here and just float over this guy.
You'll see he is variant three.
You'll see that the one that we dumped down, he is variant one.
So if I click on this, shift E, now right click, replace actors with variant one.
There you go.
Not too bad.
And now we have replaced that existing one, which was higher poly, to a lower poly model.
And this can come in pretty handy, especially if you really just want simplification in
your scene.
Nanite works great, Lumen works great, virtual shadow maps work great, but if you throw the
kitchen sink at it, you can bring anything to a crawl.
So optimizing things where you need them, you can actually lower polygons, keep it in the
background if you need it, and it works really great.
So just another option if you need to edit things in here, you don't necessarily have
to go back to your DCC.
So looking at the settings again.
We have a simplifier type here, all the different ones, QEM, normal aware and UE5 standard.
This is the one I typically use, edge claps, and minimal polygon group, preserving your
polygon groups there.
And then we also have target mode, which just controls your percentage of decimation.
And do you want to try goals like I mentioned, polygons or disease and et cetera.
That's really up to you.
Once done, it updates the triangle count in the content folder.
Similar to many DCCs, the changes approximated like I mentioned before, so keep that in mind.
So we talked about replacing it, hitting shift E, and then also just right clicking and getting
that quick change in your scene.
So I don't want to point this out at the bottom here.
No, with modeling tools, modeling tools, you can increase polygons if the LOD that came
in is too low res.
So you can remesh it.
Now you can also do that for an object that's come in as an ad-ite, and you want it to be
maybe a little bit heavier.
Now now that it's pretty great in the fact that it honors what you got from Megascans
or maybe something that you scanned on your own, you can bring that in as an ad-ite mesh
and it will get it at its highest level of detail.
So you may or may not have to remesh.
So this is really up to you and it's a case by case.
This is a bit talking a little bit more towards LOD work and pretty much Nanite is its own
type of LOD on a triangle basis versus on geometry swapping out the pieces.
So in the next video, we're going to start talking about merging geo and how that works.
Thanks again.